welcome back the white house working
overtime to convince americans that
record high gas prices are all vladimir
putin's fault
you may have noticed this week that your
gas prices have gone up i want to talk
to you a little bit about why
a lot of it has to do with vladimir
putin but part of this is on the oil
companies right now there are 9 000
approved unused permits that oil and gas
companies could tap into now to ramp up
production what do you make of that greg
uh that was interesting you know there's
a lot of price increases their hotels
going up 30 furniture 17 chicken 13 dry
cleaning baby food 8
i don't think any of that has to do with
putin's war so this inflation was going
on well before they've been making up
this crap and we know about the permits
they nobody wants to go into the weeds
on that but we know that a lot of that
stuff isn't usable and blah blah blah
blah the problem with having a democrat
in charge in this kind of ordeal
is if the consequences
match their desires they will not
mitigate the consequences we see that
now it is isn't it weird that the white
house dismisses higher oil prices it's
because they wanted
higher oil prices well before this war
started and putin invaded the ukraine
this is why they don't care about it
because they want us to pay more they
want us to feel pain at the pump so we
we reduce our oil usage or gas usage and
then we go to win you know cars with
windmills in their back seats we're also
reminded that joe biden the is an inside
weather vein whoever's in the room with
him he will simply do what they want
he's an empty vessel and right now a
room full of echo eco freaks and far
left anti-west academics are making him
do whatever they want if you could play
the control room call for number one
this is
right before the state of the union we
talked about how some biden
administration accomplishments are now
vulnerabilities here's what he said on
fossil fuels in the past
i want you to look in my eyes i
guarantee you i guarantee you we're
going to end fossil fuel one of which is
doing away with any subsidies for fossil
fuels number one number two holding them
liable
for what they have done we will double
offshore wind we will end any subsidies
for coal or any other fossil fuel
and now they're like oh but there's all
these leases you could just go ahead and
do whatever you want yeah we're going to
end you but you better drill before we
end you this is crazy
um if you're gonna blame putin fine
let's just say blame putin all you want
what are you gonna do about it they're
still not doing anything about it
they're just finger-pointing
ronald reagan one of the ways he brought
down the soviet union he told gorbachev
he said bud we're going to pump our own
oil and he got the saudis to pump oil
and that almost bankrupt the soviet
union and he sold the saudis a ton of
weapons and made the saudis happy what
are we doing now we cut arms sales to
the saudis and we're pissing them off
because we're trying to redo the iran
deal it's ass backwards god i sound like
greg what has come over me
all he he negotiates with the taliban
but he won't talk to big oil think about
that they asked him today why won't you
even have any of these oil executives
over the white house for some tea for
some croissants talk about how you guys
are going to make prices better for the
people and she goes oh well we don't
have anything on the schedule for that
well you should because you guys have to
work together with these people oil is
like food you need it to live you can't
survive america cannot survive without
oil inexpensive oil so they need to get
their act together and i'm sick of him
telling people to drive electric he
doesn't drive electric he drives
these muscle cars they get terrible
miles to the gallon saki doesn't drive
an ev
does mayor pete drive an eevee that none
of them do it's like a mask remember the
masks you guys all have to wear masks
but then you see them out and about with
no mask on partying and eating at the
french laundry that's the same concept
and it's been going on for years
remember al gore did that judge right he
was like everybody should turn off all
the lights in their house and turns out
his electricity bill was higher than
everybody else's right right you know
the whole thing the whole idea is they
want to bring iran back to the table
they want that obama iran nuclear deal
and instead of dealing with the
saudis who we should be dealing with
we're dealing now with iran and we're
dealing with iran with russia at the
table and i thought that we were
sanctioning russia but now we need them
at the table with iran to me this is
like if you need a babysitter right and
you have a 15 year old daughter who can
babysit but you say now i don't want my
daughter to babysit i'm going to go next
door but next door is a convicted
murderer and the guy's threatened to
kill you too but i'll see if he's got a
baby he's nice huh he's nice he's nice
guy all right whatever but that's what
they're doing they're dealing and
emboldening our enemies to put us in a
lurch so that we can pay them to commit
more heinous deeds that's what we're
doing dana that was the first analogy
it was pretty cool
well done
we love the analogy of the babysitter
you broke the announcement well done i
didn't know i was you were waiting for
one
oh she's got she's got a ton of them i i
don't care if you blame putin uh the oil
companies or joe biden what i
really don't like is the partisan divide
and i've never
particularly heard oil
fat cats who are reaping record profits
being their virtue extolled quite as
eloquently as it has been here i think
the notion that we want
that the democrats want intentionally
high oil prices to make the country go
green is preposterous they said it they
said it yeah they didn't say it they've
said it well i i
it is preposterous believe your ears
i believe that the other companies are
making record profits
look to where the follow the money
yeah follow it all the way to iran and
russia and maybe venezuela that's the
problem and park avenue and fifth avenue
and wall street all right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else